so sign from your movies what is the
brand of Kyle because you know you see
them once you get to a certain level you
become you know Tom ink you won't come
lizard thing so what's the brand of Kyle
because you do have to throw a person
you have to think about it you do and I
don't I mean I would be like I ideal
world like I would just like keep on
making movies and no one would even know
what I would look like but I also know
nowadays especially with the internet
and independent film primarily being
director fueled you know there's movies
at Sundance with big-name stars in them
and there's presa still just want to
talk to the director it's kind of
surreal it's only an independent film
doesn't really work that way um but I
definitely thought about it and
obviously there's a lot of connective
tissue between my first and second film
like they're both based on like memoir
essays they're both This American Life
riders named David they both deal with
like themes of sexuality i think the
movies are really different I think co
ji is a lot funnier it's a lot faster
the pacing is really different but i
also don't necessarily want to continue
down that path you know the next thing
I'm involved with is a true life story
but it's not memoir based really it's
like an actual like historical event so
it's a place in specific period it's
different it's really different it's a
lot colder it's more of drama but um
obviously I making two films that are
generally similar I don't mind sort of
being put in that place but I also hope
to be able to break out with it and
maybe do something a little more genre
or something a little different but I
guess I would love for my brand to be a
non-brand you know this way like I've
always respected Angley like even when
he's made you know he's made his fair
share of like not as great movies but
he's always made something grip he's
always made something so wildly
different than before that I really
respect that like I'd love to have that
opportunity but we'll see either way the
way I think about it the way I think
about myself is I would love an
opportunity to make something on a
bigger scale and that happens that's
great but as far as I'm concerned the
path I'm continuing down is still an
independent one still a low-budget one I
think you have to be responsible to make
movies cheaply nowadays because if
you're not doing a cheaply someone else
will and so I just try to always still
think of things smaller I just think
it's that way I can if I need to you
know i hope i can go into a project that
has financing already i don't have to do
all that but if i do have to go down
that
again then I'm prepared to and I have
projects that are prepared to be made
you know on a scalable budget
you